Voiceover: Let's do a quick
review of contango and
backwardation because they
really are opposites of each
other, but they're used in
different context, sometimes
with the exact right meaning,
sometimes with the not so
right meaning, so let's clarify
what we're talking about.
So if you hear a commodities
trader say that a market
is in contango, they're normally
just referring to the fact
that you have an upward
sloping futures curve.
So technically it'd be just
you would call it a normal
futures curve because it's
upward sloping. They would
call it contango. It sounds a
little fancier and if you were
to hear a commodities trader
say that a market is in
backwardation, they're
really just talking about an
inverted futures curve.
They're just talking about
something like this. Now, if
we were to be more precise
with those, that's how it's
used in kind of common every
day lingo but if you
wanted to be more precise,
if someone were to tell you
that we're to talk about
contango theory ... contango
theory may be in an academic
setting, then they're talking
about the notion that the
future delivery price is
actually higher than what people
expect the price to be at that
date. The problem with that
is it's just a theory and
there's no way to know ahead of
time what that expected price
actually was, so it's very
theoretical. Similarly, if
someone is talking about
backwardation theory or even,
I guess more particularly if
they use the word "normal"
backwardation. If they say
the theory of normal
backwardation, they just don't say
backwardation by itself.
They say the theory of normal
backwardation, they're talking
about the idea that the
future delivery price is
lower than some expected price
because the seller is willing
to sell it at discount so they
can essentially lock their
prices in, but once again it's
a very theoretical idea and
it's really hard to observe it
in the real world because
you actually don't know
what the expected price
is. So if someone is saying
backwardation, they're usually
just talking about an inverted,
an inverted futures curve.
If someone talks about normal
backwardation or the theory
of normal backwardation,
they're talking about the idea
that the future price, the
future delivery price is below
the market's expected price.
I've even seen the word
"normal contango" used when
they're talking about contango
theory. The idea that the
future price would be above
the expected price, so
contango theory is the
opposite of the theory of
normal backwardation. Now,
for both of the theories,
you never know what this
expected price is, so you can't
literally observe it, a
snapshot in real time and the
closest thing we can do
to observing either a real
contango in a market or
real normal backwardation
in a market, is if in the
example of contango, if the
future delivery price right now
is higher than the expected.
As we get closer and closer
to that delivery date,
it should converge or it
should move down so you can
kind of observe contango
over time when this price
moves down as we go forward
in time. This is a snapshot.
This is it moving it down
... moving down as we move
ahead in time. Same thing
for normal backwardation.
The only way that you can
really observe it or even
attempt to observe it, is
to look at what happens to
this price over time. If eight
months, the deliver price
is $50, but as we move future
... as we move forward in
time and that contract becomes
closer and closer to its
actual delivery date. It will
converge with the spot price
and it will move up, so this
observation of the futures
price moving up as you
get closer to delivery,
that's a better way of
observing that a market is
experiencing normal
backwardation. Hopefully that
clarifies some things.